WE BEGIN IN GERMANY A MAJOR
ARREST IN AN ALLEGED PLOT TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
POLICE STAGE EARLY MORNING
RAIDS DETAINING MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN PEOPLE SUSPECTED OF
CONSPIRING TO ATTACK THE
PARLIAMENT.
ANOTHER TWO DOZEN PEOPLE ARE
BEING INVESTIGATED.
PROSECUTORS SAY MEMBERS OF THE
FAR-RIGHT GROUP FOLLOWED
CONSPIRACY TENNIS AND QANON
IDEOLOGY.
GERMANY HAS BEEN STRUGGLING TO
GET A GRIP ON FAR-RIGHT
EXTREMISM IN RECENT YEARS.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S NICK
ROBERTSON FOR MORE ON THIS
DEVELOPING STORY.
HE JOINS US NOW FROM LONDON.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US, NICK.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF ARRESTS
RATE ACROSS GERMANY IN ABOUT A
DOZEN STATES PLUS TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THOSE ARRESTED?
>> YEAH, WE KNOW THAT ONE OF
THEM WHO IS BELIEVED TO BE THE
RINGLEADER IS A MINOR MEMBER OF
GERMAN ROYALTY IF YOU LIKE.
HEINRICH THE 13TH PRINCE
ROYCE'S WILL HOW HE'S BEING
REFERRED TO.
THERE ARE PICTURES OF HIS
ARREST IN A TWEED JACKET AND AN
ELDERLY LOOKING MAN IN A TREAT
JACKET.
WE ALSO KNOW THERE WAS A FORMER
MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT ARRESTED
AS WELL, A MEMBER OF THE
RIGHT-WING PARTY.
THE AFB.
THEY WERE ARRESTED AS WELL.
THE CONSPIRACY AND THE PLOTTING
AND PLANNING THE POLICE BELIEVE
WAS UNDERWAY WAS OF A VIOLENT
NATURE.
IT WAS GOING TO TARGET THE
PARLIAMENT AND TRY TO DISRUPT
IT, TRY TO STOP IT AND THEN
IMPOSE THEIR OWN PARALLEL
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY HAD
APPOINTED.
THEY HAD MINISTERS AND THEY
WERE READY TO, ESSENTIALLY, GET
RID OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND PUT IN A NEW ONE.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE THEORY A
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THEY
SUBSCRIBE TO BELIEVES THAT THE
CURRENT GERMAN STATE IS
ILLEGITIMATE.
THIS GETS TO WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THE INTERIOR MINISTER EARLIER
WHO SAID THAT THEY BELIEVE IN
VIOLENT FANTASIES AND
CONSPIRACY IDEOLOGIES.
SO IT DOES SEEM THAT THE
AUTHORITIES HAVE HANDED OFF
WHAT WOULD BE A VERY DANGEROUS
AND POTENTIALLY DEADLY PLOT AND
PLAN.
>> HIGHLY, HIGHLY CONCERNING.
TALK TO US MORE, NICK, ABOUT
THE GROUP'S TIES TO QANON AND
WHAT ELSE DOES THIS GROUP HAVE
IN COMMON WITH FAR-RIGHT
EXTREMIST AROUND THE WORLD?
>> IT BELIEVES IN DISCREDITED
YET EASILY TO ACCESS IDEOLOGIES.
THINGS THAT DON'T STAND THE
TEST OF SCRUTINY.
THE NOTION THAT THE GERMAN
STATE IS ILLEGITIMATE IS BASED
ON A THEORY THAT SAYS THAT POST
WORLD WAR II, THE NEW GERMAN
STATE THAT CAME OUT OF WORLD
WAR II WAS ESTABLISHED AND RUN
AND CONTROLLED BY THE ALLIES
WHO FOUGHT AGAINST NOT SEE
GERMANY.
OF COURSE THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
LIKE THE QANON CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, THEY TAKE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THE ONE ABOUT THE
PIZZA PARLOR THAT BECAME SO
WELL-KNOWN AND HAD PEOPLE
SHOWING UP THERE, ET CETERA.
THEY DID NOT STAND THE TEST OF
SCRUTINY.
THEY STICK TO THEM.
CLEARLY, IN THE CASE OF THIS
FORMER MP THEY HAVE INVOLVED
POLITICIANS OF PREVIOUSLY
POTENTIALLY GOOD STANDING IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND ENOUGH TO BE IN THE
BUNDESTAG.
THE CONSPIRACY ITSELF SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN SHED AND BELIEVED IN
A HARD-CORE LEVEL BY THE 52
PEOPLE THE POLICE ARE GOING
AFTER TODAY.
THEY HAD 25, THERE'S A 27
MEMBERS STILL OUT THERE.
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES HAVE
FED OUT AS WE SAW WITH QANON
AND FED INTO THE BROADER
POPULATION AND BOUGHT
SUPPORTERS WITHIN AND MEMBERS
FROM WITHIN THE BROADER
POPULATION.
IN THIS CASE, AGAIN, AS WAS
SEEN IN WASHINGTON, WHERE
MEMBERS OF QANON TURNED UP
USING VIOLENT MEANS TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE SCENE OF POWER.
THAT WAS EXACTLY THE SIMILAR
TYPE OF PLAN THAT THE PLAN WAS
TRENDING INJURY.
THEY WERE PLANNING TO USE
WEAPONS FROM WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THE GERMAN ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> NIC ROBERTSON, A DEVELOPING
STORY FOR US, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.